today we're talking about looker machine
learning courses and secop updates
i'm carter morgan and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news
registration is now open for google
cloud next october 12th to 14th
much like google cloud this year's
flagship event is designed to be open
and flexible and gives you the freedom
of choice to create the experience
that's best for you
we've designed next 21 as a customizable
digital adventure to allow for more
personalized journey
we're releasing a new set of features as
part of looker 21 that will enable
organizations to build critical data
experiences and innovative data products
faster
as well as extend their insights into
more areas of the business with packaged
analytics
faster application development more
multi-cloud environment support and more
accessible insights are just a few of
the new offerings of looker 21
check out the product features guide for
full details
if you couldn't attend our live ml
academy webinar on july 22nd
you can now watch it on demand and take
advantage of free coursera courses on ml
until august 31st
prepare for the google cloud
professional machine learning engineer
certification exam
and show your skills and badges from our
skills challenge get started today
we're thrilled to announce autonomic
security operations a stack of products
integrations blueprints technical
content and
an accelerator program to enable
customers to take advantage of our best
in-class technology stack
built on chronicle and google's deep
security operations expertise
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us and we'll see you
in the cloud